maintenant ce qui me surprend le plus
c'est que ces éléments n'ont pas été
contestées je suis quand même
extrêmement surpris que lorsqu'un
journaliste sort des éléments de cette
nature on ait eu aucun démenti
et c'est là où c'est à mon avis quelque
chose qui renforce la suspicion que nous
pouvons avoir
hier on pourra toujours nous en fera
l'annoncé trop tard il faut rester
sérieux
deuxième élément ce que je trouve
éminemment choquant est surprenant c'est
que la cour et les avocats de la défense
avaient et nous avons eu connaissance de
ces éléments jusqu'à extrêmement surpris
que la cour n'ait pas souhaité les
évoqué en préambule pour dissiper toute
suspicion
si elle n'avait strictement rien à se
reprocher
donc le déroulement de ces éléments est
éminemment suspect il est vrai que la
particularité des procédures
d'instruction qui font que nous n'avons
les mises à jour des dossiers que par
étapes
on n'a pas mis à jour en temps réel des
dossiers d'instruction fait que parfois
malheureusement on peut passer à côté
d'un élément dans des tailles
ce qui est certain c'est que je ne
m'explique toujours pas pourquoi
personne n'a jamais cherché à dissiper
cette suspicion et cela ne fait que
renforcer véritablement l'idée dans
l'esprit des parties civiles qui lie à
un très sérieux problème à ce que ça
soit pas coût de telles qualités comme
ça on est tranquille il n'y a plus de
problème de situation même si dossier
compliqué mais est ce que ce serait pas
noël
non il faut pas délocaliser parce que
encore une fois délocalisé en tête
dossier c'est extrêmement compliqué ça
voudrait dire que des magistrats doivent
reprendre une procédure qu'une grande
complexité
depuis le départ ça voudrait dire que
les gens qui travaillent vraiment sur ce
dossier et qui n'ont strictement rien à
se reprocher c'est à dire les gens du
tribunal de grande instance de besançon
suspense avant tout on juge
d'instruction serait sanctionné pour des
fautes qui n'ont pas commis ces salles
donc il faut que l'on règle le problème
de la cour mais il faut très clairement
que les magistrats et enquêteurs qu'ils
font un excellent travail continue à
avancer sur ce dossier parce que ce
serait faire le jeu de la défense et
donc le jeu peut être de cette
éventuelle collusion avec les cours que
de retirer le dossier à des magistrats
de grande qualité
et d'ailleurs ils sont deux une telle
qualité qu'ils sont éminemment conspué
par le dr peschier par sa défense